our team is the elite of the elite for
the heart soul of this very Beach we
protect when other people don't want to
protect and we go above and beyond
[Music]
if you want me you can have me some
other time
we're staring into the abyss here City
Council's already cut our funding it's
up to us to restore the Baywatch brand
I'm Matt Brodie ready for duty
you just pick my boobs I usually look at
my face I'm trying but it's so close to
your boobs yeah this is the guy you
think it's a good PR opportunity for us
do some shots he's reckless
with two gold medals I mean gold medals
do you have probably zero we got a dead
body on our Beach that's not our job
my gut says there's a bad [ __ ] going on
over there and my balls say we need to
check it out eyeballs say it's just take
it easy right
what are your balls sound like three
year old girls I don't know man that's
just how they talk but they're wise
welcome to Baywatch Sean are you ready
surprise
why does she always look like she's
running in slow-mo you see it too
you turned the canals into the dam
x-games yeah
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit how do I explain this so that
you people understand you people you
people oh you don't get to say that
you're just ten right oh come on brother
[Music]
your average chocolate Wiscasset your
big fake [ __ ] Oh Mitch
[Music]
I'm that Brody ready for duty
welcome to Baywatch
you just look at my boobs I you should
look at my face I'm trying but it's so
close to your boobs ha
you